hey reject nation I'm Greg Alba watch
today shocking moments caught on camera
numero uno from the channel fact fiction
a girlfriend watches this channel
actually I've never seen this video but
I wanted to say really quick before we
hop it in this full link in the
description Bonnie he is from focus TV
network where he did an interview him
and renwood so I have to invite on the
channel I said I'd invite her on to they
interviewed me it was a great really fun
interview link in the description box
for the youtube link but you could go
check out the focus TV network website
plenty of talk shows on there yes guys
I'm telling you it's worth watching I
want to give a patient the day shout out
though to a man named totally jumbled TJ
this guy lives in a different state he's
been a longtime follower of this channel
TJ recently had a baby I thought it was
appropriate to chat him out in this
video live shocking moments caught on
camera because he was caught on camera
punching his baby in the crib and then
what did he do he spit on his wife
afterwards why this man hasn't been
arrested yet I don't know what I will
tell you this video that he did is
hilarious oh my gosh so funny I you you
would think punching a baby and sweet on
your wife is not something to joke about
that isn't but when you watch this video
you're like yeah he really found the
fine line between serious reality and
comedy TJ got to give you credit for
that
let's talk bit of this yeah huh we can
handle it I can I can do it I can do it
Wow matter fact affection it's a good
time nowadays we have the resources to
film anything and for it to be viewed by
anyone anything can be caught on camera
from happy moments to just plain to
weird moments this also means that
sometimes the most jaw-dropping events
whoa today max action presents five
shocking moments that were caught on
camera electronics - July 1st 2016 the
incident occurred in California at
around 2:30 p.m. where a woman and her
four-year-old daughter can be seen
entering the store the young mother was
waiting in line and had her baby in her
arms while her daughter was playing with
a candy machine close to the front door
after standing around for a few moments
a man can be seen grabbing the
four-year-old girl by the arm and
attempting to abduct her in broad
daylight what's a young mother and
another customer immediately ran outside
and thankfully the little girl was able
to break free the woman explained to the
store owner that she saw the man in the
parking lot and he was staring at her
and her daughter as they walked into the
store he would try anything the would-be
kidnapper attended to escape from the
scene but was quickly tackled to the
ground by members of the public and was
held until police arrived the suspect
has been identified as 24 year old Terry
Ranson who has been charged with
kidnapping and child cruelty the young
girl and her mother baby are standardly
shaken up by the incident but thankfully
the four-year-old did not suffer any
physical injury that's insanity what an
idiot
they were actually able to catch him
it's like the worst thought-out
kidnapping I've ever heard of yeah and
now he's going to jail for life baby die
that stuff his footage that has been
trending on the internet for a while now
in the video which has been speculated
to have been filmed in India a child
with black hair is seen getting out of a
window on a high tower block
the child appears to be happy while on
the ledge and even bounces up and down
he or she goes back inside and then
repeats it all over again at one point
it looks as if the toddler is about to
fall off the edge due to how close he or
she gets but somehow the child remains
on the ledge eventually a pair of arms
can be seen grabbing the child and
pulling him or her back inside the
apartment thankfully the kid was
unharmed however this could have easily
been a different story I would never
even do that I can't handle this - this
is ridiculous oh my god they got web
sling by spider-man although parents
aren't watching yeah this one was nuts
no about this one knows where the
airplane fight may be this tragic
dashcam video shows trans-asia Airways
flight 235 final moments before flipping
a taxi into bridge and then crashing
into a river in Taipei Taiwan in
February of 2015
43 people were killed including the
planes entire cockpit crowd only 15
people survived the crash after the
plane took off the captain can be heard
saying that he pulled the wrong side
throttle he mistakenly throttled down a
still running engine following a glitch
with the other engine it was reported by
the aviation Safety Council at Taiwan
that the pilot in charge failed his
initial simulator training in 2014 final
report in 2016 listed pilot error as the
cause of the crash
it's actually a very underwhelming yeah
just clip the front of the car Tigger
Tigger tech in late July 2016
CCTV caught the shocking moments a woman
was attacked by a tiger at the bottling
wildlife world in China at the safari
park which has 10,000 wild animals
allows visitors to drive through the
tiger enclosure by themselves or as part
of a tour but does not permit anyone to
leave their vehicle
the young woman seen in the footage did
not listen to these warnings and stepped
outside of the car and walked over to
the driver's side it is believed that
this was due to a family argument
moments after the male opened his door
the female was attacked while Siberian
tiger probably before being dragged away
the male driver and a middle-aged woman
who was believed to be the young girl's
mother immediately got out of the car
and ran over to the girl in hopes of
saving her life unfortunately just
off-camera another tiger viciously
attacked and mauled the mother and this
led to her death o rescue staff managed
to save the young woman's life and she
was taken to the hospital with serious
injuries not much is known about what
condition the young woman is in now
that's really sad that's it's insanely
tragic the mom tried saving her life I
didn't know where he just came and
pulled her in oh my god it isn't the
first time something like this has
happened at the park in 2009 a foolish
man decided to climb the 10-foot fence
into an enclosure and was killed by a
Siberian tiger and in 2014 he was mauled
to death by a Bengal tiger when he
stepped out of his Jeep in order to
relieve himself
when speeding
goes wrong this is number five speeding
as always this upsetting and shocking
video shows the final moments leading up
to the death watch battled East Sussex
on a 12 2015 the two friends Kyle care
for at age 20 were high in prescription
and illegal drugs when they decided to
get in their car and speed along a
residential road at night Owen who was a
father of one is the person recording
the video while Kerr furred is the one
driving the video shows the renault clio
reaching up to 90 miles per hour due to
their carelessness their car crashes
into the st. michael's parish church
wall and flips over several times while
landing on its roof sabda old men died
at the scene the pair had gained
numerous injuries and they were already
dead once fire and rescue services got
them out of the car
the heartbroken families of the two
young men were very upset when watching
the video however they gave permission
for the video to be released in order to
deter anyone from driving under the
influence of drugs or alcohol
and to discourage people from speeding
Owens mother hopes that the video can
provide a positive impact on other young
people yeah
[Music]
Wow
why did is he's being under the
influence
[Music]
they swarming into Lane
it's full throttle in a residential area
[Music]
yeah
very on the sidewalk glory
[Music]
Madhavi fastest at almost 100 yeah it's
not even like 90 bragging well Harry I
thought we did on a fun note you know
figure this is our last video we filmed
the day why not end on an upper why not
another you know cuz I knew that was
gonna be featured in here yeah footage
of people right before they died tragic
that honestly I don't really speed
especially in Resident now like if you
ever ever speeds on a freeway yeah
shouldn't speed like shouldn't speed
under the influence no that is magic
what happened it's very tragic I
actually respect the family for letting
that footage be out there because I
think that can be life-changing for
someone actually watching and go like
maybe I shouldn't be doing what I'm
sometimes okay with doing because I have
a friend who lost a friend to a speeding
accident my friend used to speed all the
time and then after that one accident
he's a careful driver it changed his
life I think is releasing that better be
careful after seeing these tragedies man
the first one though
yes that's scary for the mother but that
is a stupidest thing I've ever stupidest
things I've ever see I can't when people
do that yeah
and then where's he gonna run off with
the
he's getting here cause his security
cameras and it's in public it's in broad
daylight on a street well he was in jail
for life for that was he gonna try to do
like a ransom situation or was it gonna
be on the situation for the kidnap I
don't know horrible things you know like
Silence of the Lambs stuff that's just a
really bad that's a really super
criminal right there that second one
though with the baby yeah there have
been babies who have died from that do
you know I haven't heard about any of
them but Eric Clapton who did the song
tears from heaven that songs about his
baby who fell out of a window oh my god
climbed out a window baby so like when I
saw this part when they announced it but
he went inside and came out again didn't
even see the first my parents how
neglectful you have to be incredibly
neglectful that's it when I have a baby
it's staying in the basement smart till
it's five years old very smart very
smart can't walk yet in basement chains
and everything like Boo Radley from
tequila Mockingbird yep see we should we
should adopt together there be a great
co-parent yeah what was it planed oh
yeah you know it's sad about this like
if I was the one with the camera he
would have reacted a lot more strong I
would've reacted more strongly and I
would have been like how lucky are we
man I don't know how I so lucky to get
that footage it would be an actual
thought that I think someone would go
wow I really lucked out with getting
that shot didn't I though of course it
was awful what happened that was I mean
it's crazy honest I mean I rarely hear
about people actually surviving the
plane crash yeah well survivors yeah 12
to 15 somewhere there survived at a
forty-five or something that's a lot of
deaths I'm surprising what this pilots
still fly when they receive a dose em
yeah and they'd still let them fly yeah
that cab driver dude yeah I'm you
imagine you're randomly driving [__]
planes it's like I'm sorry it really is
LAX or something
like can I get your insurance money here
- and that's the 2h it's slightly
comedic from the angle of what we
watched we are horrible people for
fighting the humor in this terrible from
years ago the tiger won though man
that's a heartbreaking one yeah that
isn't seen these Tigers just come out of
nowhere like that
the other ones kind of have like there's
always someone who's kind of dumb or
shouldn't have been in like a tiger that
wants you that one is this completely
Iran yeah cuz like even the last one
these people shouldn't have been under
the influence and speeding the first one
would have dumb criminal the second one
neglectful parents the third one this
guy should have been flying this one
though like for a Tigers it just it's
like you don't expect that I wouldn't
expect that and then with the tragic
part is the mom tried saving her and
then some other tiger attacked her and
thank you yeah so the mom died trying to
mom died trying to save her daughter and
then a daughter had horrible wounds I
don't know about you but I'm so happy to
be here in this moment like this I'm so
happy we could share and relish and the
joy and positivity and go about our day
yeah stay safe out there look out for
speeding cars yes look out for planes in
the air yes be careful the Tigers and
watch your kids watch your kids this
video encompasses all the necessary yeah
unless there's a survival right here
right here yes yeah yeah he's safe out
there well they have a number two five
shocking Moses has some time Wow
hey guys well if you want to feel good
and leave a comment below tell us when
you catch any shocking moments on camera
you guys can subscribe to the reject
nation sad stuff that we saw today click
that notification but entertaining stuff
that's what counts most it's also
educational check us on patreon full
like TV show reactions weekly Q&A boom
and Harry Howard follow him on the insta
and check out focused TV network
including the interview him and read did
their professional studio yeah
love you guys I miss it